In order to start resolving
ambiguities of the kind
the occur with the earthquake story,
we need a new knowledge representation
called a traumatic rule system.
A traumatic rule system is
a type of frame system,
where the frame represents an action or
event identified by a word.
The word caused forth a number of
expectations about the roles that
are connected with
that particular event.
David, can you think of an example
of the thematic-role frame?
>> So one simple example that comes
to mind for me is the word throw.
I know that if a throw action has taken
place, a few things have to be in play.
I expect there to be
someone doing the throwing.
I expect something to be thrown.
I might expect a target
specified by the word at or
a destination specified by the word to.
So, for example,
I throw the ball to a choke, or
I throw the ball at a choke,
depending on how nice I'm feeling.
>> [LAUGH] Note that even though
David isn't talking about a specific
instance of throwing,
he's still able to generate expectations
with the general action of throwing.
This shows what a traumatic
case frame does for you.
It is able to generate expectations.
Let us look at how it would
actually work in action.